Transcription: bernard etienne
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonjour, je vais commencer par vous poser
une petite question, toute petite.
Trois millimètres.
Est-ce que c’est un problème
si la mer monte de 3 mm, selon vous ?
Levez la main si vous pensez
que c’est un problème.
Oui, quelques mains se lèvent.
Trois mm par an,
c’est pas grand-chose,
on peut attendre l’année prochaine.
Eh bien non, en fait,
on va voir que trois mm,
c’est quand même énorme.
Quand j’avais neuf ans,
j’habitais à La Jolla
en Californie du sud, à côté de San Diego,
mais plus particulièrement
à 650 mètres de la mer.
Donc, après l’école,
j’aimais bien aller voir la mer,
voir les plongeurs sous-marins
qui étaient là,
les surfeurs et aussi les phoques.
J’étais en pleine immersion déjà
dans ce monde, ce monde maritime.
Et puis, à cette époque-là,
il y avait à la télévision
les épisodes du commandant Cousteau,
Le Monde sous-marin de Jacques Cousteau,
et juste après
il y avait Flipper le dauphin.
Alors moi, je rêvais d'être en immersion
toute la journée avec mon dauphin,
mon dauphin à moi.
Et puis voilà, je crois que déjà là,
j’ai commencé à être passionné par la mer
et je me suis orienté vers l’idée
que j’allais étudier la mer de plus près.
Donc j’ai fait des maths, de la physique,
des sciences de la terre,
et à partir de là, mon prof me dit :
« L’avenir, c’est le spatial. »
L’avenir, c’est le spatial, c’est vrai !
Depuis l’espace, on a une vue
imprenable sur la Terre,
en fait c’est 70 % de mer,
et avec les satellites, on fait
le tour du monde en 80 minutes,
ce qui est bien mieux
que Jules Verne en 80 jours.
Et donc j’ai trouvé ma voie,
j’ai continué,
j’ai fait une thèse de doctorat
et ensuite un séjour au MIT à Boston
et là, je regardais la mer,
je prenais les données des satellites,
que je mettais dans les modèles
de circulation de l’Atlantique et tout ça.
Et puis,
il y a eu en fait un moment très important
qui a déclenché cette vocation,
c’est que j’étais déjà dans le milieu
de la recherche très jeune.
Mon père et ma tante
faisaient la recherche,
et j’ai eu l’occasion de visiter
des labos de recherche.
Et je vous conseille de toujours
vous approcher
du métier  que vous voudrie
faire plus tard
et aller parler avec les gens.
Et en fait, un 24 décembre
au matin, très tôt,
je reçois un coup de téléphone
pour faire un remplacement
dans une expédition
océanographique en Antarctique.
Et là, c’était 44 jours de bonheur,
44 jours d’émotions.
Et la beauté de l’océan Antarctique
a vraiment confirmé ma vocation.
Après, j’ai été embauché
à l’Agence spatiale européenne.
Vous connaissez, ESA, les trois lettres
qu’il y a sur la fusée Ariane,
mais vous connaissez pas forcément ESA
parce qu’on est un petit peu
moins connu que la NASA.
Donc l’ESA c’est la NASA européenne.
Et on travaille
avec toutes les agences nationales
et on a en développement
des satellites.
On en a seize en opération et on a, dans
les cartons, encore quatre satellites.
Quand j’ai été embauché, on avait
un seul satellite, c’était le premier.
Et maintenant, tous ces petits points
que vous voyez sur la carte,
c’est pratiquement un Ted talk,
une conférence TED.
Et notre but, notre mission
à l’Agence Spatiale Européenne,
c’est de prendre le pouls de la Terre,
c’est de faire des bilans de santé
et d’informer les stratèges qui signent
des traités pour préserver la terre.
Mon satellite préféré, c’est un satellite
qui embarque un altimètre radar.
L’altimètre radar, c’est très simple :
on envoie une onde électromagnétique.
Elle rebondit sur la mer.
On mesure le temps et on a la distance.
Avec la distance, on sait où est l’orbite.
On calcule le niveau de la mer.
Et je vous ai dit trois millimètres.
Le satellite est à 800 kilomètres, donc
c’est quand même assez impressionnant,
impressionnant ce qu’on peut faire
depuis l’espace.
Alors, ce que j’ai à vous dire maintenant,
c’est simplement que ces études
que l’on fait avec nos satellites,
ça permet de comprendre le climat,
de comprendre son évolution.
Premièrement, on voit
qu’avec le réchauffement,
les glaces fondent.
Et là , c’est le glacier du Rhône en 1900.
Cent ans plus tard, il y en a plus.
On sait que la planète se réchauffe
et l’eau se réchauffe aussi
puisque vous avez entendu juste avant,
l’océan absorbe plus de 90%
de la chaleur en excès à cause
de l’effet de serre.
Et donc si l'eau absorbe la chaleur,
elle se dilate.
Donc la mer monte,
la mer monte parce que
les glaciers fondent,
la mer monte parce que l’eau se dilate
et la mer monte parce que
les calottes polaires fondent aussi.
Et ça affecte plus particulièrement
les villes côtières, évidemment,
comme La Baule, les marais salants,
mais aussi Venise.
Et cette photo me rappelle ma passion
pour la plongée sous-marine.
Alors je me suis dit, je vais aller
visiter Venise, mais maintenant,
pour aller visiter Venise, voilà
comment il faut s’équiper.
Et on se concentre sur les villes côtières
parce qu’en fait, c’est là
où il y a la plupart de la population.
600 millions de personnes habitent
à moins de dix mètres d’altitude
et ils seront 1,6 milliard en 2060.
Et ça, c’est quelque chose qui nous amène
à regarder non seulement
le niveau moyen de la mer,
et ça, c’est une courbe :
depuis 1993, on voit l’évolution du niveau
moyen de toute la planète, de la mer.
Et le pire ici, c'est que ce qu'on voit,
c'est que ça s'accélère.
On dit trois mm par an en moyenne,
mais en fait, on est plutôt proche
de cinq mm par an.
Et en fait, on devrait commencer à réduire
un peu les émissions à effet de serre,
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
et pouvoir
essayer de réduire l’impac
que les humains ont sur le climat.
En fait, on fait des mesures
très, très précises.
Je vous ai dit, on arrive à avoir 3 mm
de changements par an
depuis 800 kilomètres d’altitude
et parce qu’on traite les données
très méticuleusement,
mais en plus, on le fait d’une
manière indépendante.
Et là, ce que vous voyez,
c’est la somme de toutes
ces contributions, donc je vous ai dit :
l’expansion thermique, la mer monte,
les glaciers qui fondent, la mer monte,
les calottes polaires qui fondent,
la mer monte,
et puis aussi les échanges
avec les eaux terrestres.
Il se trouve qu’on déverse de l’eau,
qui est naturellement sur la Terre,
dans les océans.
Donc on voit aussi cette partie
là, et la somme des contributions,
c’est la ligne rouge.
Elle se superpose à la mesure indépendante
que l’on fait avec l’altimètre radar
du niveau moyen des mers qui augmente.
Et là , on est content.
on sait que, en amont, n’en déplaise
aux climatosceptiques,
la mer monte de trois mm par an
depuis 1993 et en fait de cinq mm par an
depuis les dix dernières années.
Mais ce qui est important, c’est de savoir
que tous les humains ne sont pas égaux
devant la montée de la mer.
Cette carte, vous voyez des couleurs
différentes suivant les régions.
Plus c’est rouge, plus ça monte.
Et en fait, ça monte trois fois plus
que la valeur moyenne
que l’on calcule sur tout le globe.
Et ça, c'est très important.
Surtout, il est important de voir
comment ça affecte vraiment à la côte.
Avec le satellite, c’est très difficile
car quand on fait des mesures
en pleine mer, on mesure la mer.
Quand on fait des mesures à la côte,
on mesure à moitié la Terre,
à moitié la mer.
Et donc on travaille
très, très précisément
pour voir dans tous les endroits
où le satellite passe
comment la mer monte.
Et là, on voit, on a une image
de comment ça se passe
un peu dans toutes les régions du globe.
Alors on me demande
que faire ?
Donc vous avez déjà eu quelques
présentations qui vous disent
qu’il faut économiser l’énergie,
qu’il faut économiser
les gaz à effet de serre,
ne pas mettre dans l’atmosphère
des gaz à effet de serre.
Et aussi, je pense que c’est une manière
de ne pas trop consommer l’énergie,
c’est aussi de recycler tout
ce qu’on peut parce que, en fait,
les choses sont très…
consommatrices d’énergie quand on extrait
des métaux, du plastique
et même du papier, tout ça.
Et en fait, ce qu’on essaie de faire,
c’est aussi de regarder
comment est-ce qu’on peut gérer tout ça ?
En fait, on fait des…
On fait le TRI, T.R.I.,
les Territoires à Risque d’Inondation
et territoires à risque de submersion.
Et donc on fabrique, avec des ordinateurs,
des modèles qui nous permettent
de simuler comment,
avec l’eau qui va monter,
une ville comme celle de Gâvres,
dans le Morbihan, à côté de Lorient,
va être inondée
lors d’une onde de tempête.
Et ça c’est la fameuse tempête Johanna sur
lequel on a beaucoup travaillé en 2008.
Et donc on voit comment, vague après vague
avec toutes les conditions
les vents, la pression atmosphérique, etc…
comment la ville est inondée.
D’abord dans les parties basses,
le terrain de foot.
Et après, petit à petit, les zones
qui vont être inondées.
Et ça, c’est très important
parce que si on veut se défendre
et se préparer à des ondes de submersion,
dues à l’élévation du niveau de la mer,
on a ces outils.
Ensuite, on fait des projections.
Les modèles de climat nous permettent
de faire des projections.
Et on peut que le résultat,
c’est qu’on peut s’attendre
à un mètre d’élévation du niveau de la mer
d’ici 2100,
mais peut-être plus
parce qu’il peut y avoir
des effondrements des calottes polaires
qui sont très difficiles à prévoir.
Et donc tout ça, c’est rapporté
dans les rapports du GIEC,
il y en a encore un qui est sorti
au mois de février sur les risques.
Et notre but, c’est de fournir
des données pour améliorer
la connaissance des modèles.
Donc voilà.
Alors que faire au niveau local ?
Je ne vais pas vraiment vous dire
exactement quoi faire
parce que vous l’avez entendu déjà
et vous savez.
Mais je pense que c’est très important
d’éviter le gaspillage,
ce qui veut dire faire des économies
pour ne pas émettre
trop de gaz à effet de serre.
Et pourquoi le gaz à effet
de serre est important ?
Maintenant, on va rentrer dans le détail,
En fait dans un climat stable,
on a l’énergie émise par le Soleil
reçue par la Terre,
qui est équivalente à l’énergie
qui est réémise par la Terre.
Et en fait là , on est
en déséquilibre total.
Et ça, c'est très important de savoir
que c'est un gros déséquilibre.
Un watt par mètre carré.
Qu’ est-ce que c’est,
un watt par mètre carré ?
Ça, c’est un petit radiateur électrique
portatif de 1500 watts.
Ça, c’est un terrain de football.
Et on peut dire qu’on a
cinq radiateurs de 1500 watts
en permanence allumés
sur chaque partie de la Terre,
l’équivalent d’un terrain de football.
C'est énorme.
Et c’est dû au fait que l’énergie
n’est pas renvoyée vers l’espace
est piégée par cette couverture,
ce qu’on appelle l’effet de serre.
Donc les gaz à effet de serre,
essentiellement le CO2.
Donc
qu’est-ce qu’on va pouvoir faire ?
S'intéresser essentiellement
à comment réduire le CO2.
Et moi, ce que je peux vous dire, c’est
que la transition énergétique,
c’est très important,
mais on n’y arrivera pas avec seulement
des panneaux solaires et des éoliennes.
Il nous faudra bien plus et par exemple
récupérer l’énergie des vagues.
L’énergie des vagues, il y en a
pratiquement tout au long de l’année.
Et même s’il fait très beau chez vous,
il peut y avoir une tempête
au milieu de l’Atlantique
et il y a de la houle,
et on peut toujours fabriquer de
l’énergie avec les vagues.
Vous aurez une présentation,
“L’aventure du GIEC”, ça c’est bien.
Ils font un travail remarquable
mais il faudrait qu’en fait
qu’ils grandissent 1000 fois.
Il faudrait qu'ils soient 1000 fois
plus grand pour y arriver.
Et le message que je voudrais vous faire
passer, le message essentiel, c'est que
avec les satellites,
on observe la situation,
on fait le pouls, on prend le pouls
de la Terre, on fait le bilan de santé
et on peut voir deux choses :
soit quand on passe des traités
et que on fait des efforts,
la situation s’améliore
ou on peut même mesurer
les effets de l’inaction.
Et en fait, l’inaction coûtera
beaucoup plus cher
que faire en sorte qu’on puisse mitiger
les effets des changements climatiques.
Et toutes les informations qui viennent
des satellites sont à votre disposition.
Tous les services qu’on a fait en aval
pour utiliser ces données
pour les faire arriver sur votre téléphone
portable sont à votre disposition.
Toutes les innovations que l’on fait
en amont, en recherche et développement,
sont à votre disposition et en fait,
bénéficient à la gestion de la planète.
Donc moi, ce que je peux vous dire,
c’est prenez-les, regardez-les,
faites-en quelque chose,
surtout les jeunes qui bricole bien avec
des petites applications, du code etc.
et vous pouvez les utilise
au niveau local.
Mais si vous voulez regarder
la planète globale,
toutes ces données sont
absolument à votre disposition.
C’est le message essentiel
que j’ai à vous donner ce soir.
Ces données vont nous aider
à mesurer l’effort que l’on fait
et nous encourager à faire plus d’efforts.
Et je vous remercie beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)